it is seriously expensive to be a human
on planet earth but these 10 cities take
it to a whole new level think your cost
of living is high you should try living
one of these cities the list of the 10
most expensive cities includes Paris
Ozma Zurich Sydney Melbourne Geneva
Copenhagen Hong Kong soul New York and
Singapore taking the top spot the
worldwide cost of living report compares
a hundred and thirty three cities with
New York City set as a standard base for
the study according to the report a loaf
of bread a bottle of wine and a pack of
cigarettes in Singapore will set a
customer back thirty nine dollars an
eleven cents alright so we all lived in
New York City at different times in our
lives was cost one of the reasons you
got the hell out of there I don't know
back when I lived in New York City it
was cheap though you know is it wasn't
so at the 50s wedding done but I lived
there in 2003 I guess when you could
still live in Manhattan but you can't
live in Manhattan anymore I mean that's
just out of the question you can't live
in Williamsburg anymore and that's out
of the question and and now people are
just moving further and further out i'm
just i'm upset that our own los angeles
didn't even make that list yeah so
speaking of los angeles you're not
you're happy it didn't make the most
expensive cities live list seems like a
really expensive city ER oh well I lived
in New York my entire life New York City
to last like 10 years or so and I moved
to the LA two years ago and I still when
I go to the supermarket or when I just
buy anything or gas whatever it is I
still can't believe how cheap it is here
and I know it's not really cheap but
that's just because New York is bonkers
so when I lived in New York I was
couchsurfing living in bunk beds and
like eating pizza every day so I was
spending no money I was an unpaid intern
I and being a girl I'm not gonna lie
it's much easier to get things for free
you know that's not a sustainable plan
really go out and like drinks or bot or
you can go out and food is bot nice are
you saying we can't go out and get
drinks bought yeah we ought to go
bystander oh I thought bring drinks
before yeah but this is not a
sustainable way that people can live
their life of just this is what probably
hustlers do and like a criminal's to no
no I'm just saying is you can't sort of
compare the lifestyle of
but when is she thrived in New York
successfully that you were trying to
make well I had a great time and I
didn't end up leaving because it was too
expensive i had opportunities elsewhere
it was more like this city is so
exciting and there are ways to get by
that I found where you weren't spending
a ton of money but I also imagine that
if you're if you are making a living or
raising a family or doing anything like
that where you have to be have to be
spending money and not sleeping on
couches then I think the problem with
these places happens when like in New
York where everybody moved out of the
city and then everybody moved out of
Williamsburg and further and further you
just lose the core of who your artists
are who at least could afford to live
down the first what makes the top of the
list was the top Singapore Singapore Wow
yeah are we going to Singapore can we
take the show on the road to Singapore
maybe see what's going on is I think we
should try to find out or any of them
did any of those cities shocked you I'm
in Paris obviously like a bunch of them
they seems Eric like these seem like
expensive places to live it was
interesting to me that so many of them
were in Asia where at the same time you
have some of the most poverty also in
the entire world and often like within
the same city itself right i mean we
were in port-au-prince a couple of weeks
ago in city soleil which is the poorest
neighborhood essentially in the Western
Hemisphere and this idea that you can
live there and everyone does off of an
average of what three hundred dollars a
month and like people are dancing and
people are happy and you go to New York
and you're in the subway and people are
pissing okay depressed like it just goes
to show that how much you're making and
where you're living all that is so
relative you beat me to my final
question the correlation do you think so
you guys think there's no college
because I agree with that even I went
back to New York a couple weeks ago and
that subway thing you see these
miserable people and then it gets on you
you actually feel it versus you live in
some other cities i mean there's plenty
people that live on beaches they're
pretty happy right yeah maybe they're
have it as much money it may also have
to do with the proximity to to wealth
that makes you consider your situation
as poor you know and we were talking
about this to this idea of if you don't
know that you don't have much because
there's no relative comparison to
someone who does have a lot you can
maybe be happier than if you're in a
city like Singapore or Zurich or Paris
or New York where there are the homeless
and the extraordinarily wealthy living
side by side
uh that that on both ways right there's
there's a sense of inequality and
unfairness to that for people on both
sides of yeah but it's also in
port-au-prince is just a great city and
you have all the freedoms in the world
to do whatever you want and then in
Singapore you can't even spit gum out on
the street you know so that's it you're
not gonna find the happiest people there
that's right sure so final thought to
your point how important is having that
artist community that that sort of area
where people can escape to to create
that's a huge part of what's important
about a city right yeah no I think it's
the moat it's the most important part
right like you have to have you have to
have a place where people are creating
and also paying homage to this today
that they're living in I mean that's
where you find the heart and soul of
these places is always in the artists
districts and very rarely in the
financial districts no offense or
offense there's not a lot of creative be
their creative financially but that's
about it anyway what do you think do you
guys live in any of these 10 cities we
want to know how you're surviving over
there let us know in the comments right
down below
you